c'est vrai que son histoire c'est un peu
comme on dit au Brésil c'est un peu une
telenovela quoi
Da Costa bonsoir vous êtes une jeune
carioca de 22 ans top model d'envergure
international notamment l'image du
parfum Shalimar de Guerlain
mais vous n'êtes pas Brenda un mannequin
comme les autres vous avez vu vous
battre 10 fois plus que les autres pour
y arriver car vous êtes né sourde
et vous racontez tout ça dans un livre
Comment dépit du handicap votre rêve
d'enfant est devenu réalité
alors brenda est né en 1982 le 8
novembre d'ailleurs c'est son
anniversaire mardi prochain que ça
intéresse et si sous sept mois après
votre naissance votre père se rend
compte de quelque chose il fait le test
de la radio il met la radio à fond et il
n'obtient aucune réaction
et malgré la vie d'un certain nombre de
pédiatres qui qui disent bon elle est
tout à fait normale elle a rien lui il
est persuadé en fait que vous êtes
sourde
alors vos parents s'occupent de vous
d'une façon exemplaire il vous prenne
une nounou particulière il vous envoie
chez le meilleur orthophoniste du Brésil
vous êtes une enfant très entourée donc
on veut lui apprendre quand elle est
toute petite à dire papa et maman donc
on lui essaye de lui expliquer comment
on dit Papa et Maman et finalement au
bout d'un moment après les efforts
surhumains le premier mot qu'elle dit
dans sa vie c'est Coca-Cola c'est le
premier mot qu'elle a dit
voilà alors à 3 ans et demi elle est
mise dans une école mais justement ses
parents ont pris soin de pas la mettre
dans un établissement pour les sourds et
les malentendants c'est-à-dire une
espèce de ghetto de sourd-muet elle est
mise dans une école normale quoi
elle faisait sa thérapie dans la journée
après à l'école et elle allait dans une
école
de 5 ans elle décide de devenir
mannequin
et elle le fera c'est quand même
extraordinaire pas donné à tout le monde
non
ensuite elle s'épanouit elle apprend à
lire sur les lèvres elle est au lycée
elle a une bande elle a un vrai danger
voilà un premier petit ami voilà et
malgré tout ce petit ami se Léandro
finalement boit l'aime bien mais elle
continue elle a une espèce de
d'opiniâtreté comme ça à réussir son son
rêve sa légende personnelle et elle
rencontre un talent scout de l'agence
Élite qui lui fait faire des photos tout
ça mais qui repart à New York et un jour
elle va dans une agence au Brésil qui
s'appelle l'agence mega alors elle
montre son boucle le directeur dit c'est
formidable enfin c'est pas possible quoi
elle est sourde ça va être compliqué
quand on va l'envoyer chez les clients
on va pas y arriver ça va être très
difficile
et là en sortant du bureau de ce
directeur c'est miraculeux ce qui se
passe elle s'effondre elle tombe en
larmes parce que à cause de sa surdité
elle n'a pas été retenue par cette
agence de mannequin méga et passe à ce
moment-là le PDG de l'agence méga le
président directeur général qui a un
fils sourd c'est extraordinaire comme
histoire est-ce que c'est incroyable en
même temps aussi c'est que ce monsieur
il avait beaucoup de moyens c'est un
homme riche brésilien et en même temps
c'est incroyable parce que lui en fait
il a eu beaucoup de problèmes avec son
fils son fils il était dans une école de
pour sourde il n'avait pas du tout et
Fatima sa mère et Brenda
avec avec ses moyens en fait elle a
réussi vraiment que sa fille elle est
complètement épanouie qu'elle
en fait grâce aussi
le patron de l'agence lui dit mais c'est
pas un problème mon fils aussi est sourd
donc je vais vous aider et d'ailleurs
elle sort avec le neveu de ce PDG qui
était photographe de mode elle a quand
même pas oublié de sortir avec le neveu
du PDG
et alors elle commence à travailler
comme comme mannequin et là vous partez
voilà c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire
qu'elle part à New York à l'âge de 20
ans pour l'agence Élite donc une agence
extrêmement importante et à peine arrivé
elle court les castings alors c'est
terrible parce que bon d'abord il fait
froid ça change du Brésil il y a la
neige et comme elle a pas de portable
contrairement aux autres elle est
obligée à chaque fois de repasser à
l'agence pour savoir s'il y a du nouveau
parce que les autres filles se
contentent d'appeler sur le portable
donc c'est c'est très compliqué elle a
été extrêmement courageuse t'imagines
quoi seul elle était sale et alors en
fait elle a dépensé tout son argent en
taxi parce que normalement les filles
arrivent bon il y a le premier jour
c'est toujours un peu dur mais elle
prend le métro bon Brenda comme elle
avait peur déjà c'est faut voir c'est
c'est en plus une autre langue qu'elle
comprend alors là elle comprend vraiment
rien c'est elle comprend rien alors elle
elle dépensé tout l'argent qu'elle a
amené en taxi parce qu'elle prenait des
taxis pour aller partout extrêmement
courageux parce qu'en plus les gens
n'aiment pas un soir elles dorment dans
un foyer où il y a plusieurs mannequins
qui habitent
GoBack home quoi c'est-à-dire qu'en plus
en plus de tous les problèmes qu'il y
avait à débarqué à New York en étant
sourde il y a encore les autres qui ne
s'aiment pas
voilà et puis à force de courage ça
commence à marcher et le 14 juin 2004
vous faites la couverture du journal
Elle et là c'est un petit peu le début
de la gloire quoi c'est après il y a eu
shalimart tout ça puis maintenant c'est
un top model qui qui marche très bien
c'est vrai que son histoire c'est un peu
comme on dit au Brésil c'est un peu une
telenovela quoi
elle dit oui mais elle est très contente
que son histoire c'est comme une telle
un nouvel an mais bientôt vous êtes
opéré non
il y a une possibilité oui que Brennan
va être opérée le seul problème avec
cette opération c'est que cette
opération c'est pas garanti même si elle
est opérée qu'elle va écouter peut-être
elle va écouter imaginons
30%, peut-être mais peut-être pas mais
après il faut penser c'est qu'elle a
jamais entendu un bruit de sa vie de sa
vie alors
pour elle une fois que si elle va
entendre après il faut qu'elle fasse une
thérapie une nouvelle thérapie parce que
dès qu'elle va entendre un bruit ça va
être ça va être un truc de folie
[Rires]
tu t'en sors bien pour l'instant
on met des implants cochléaires et c'est
tout à fait extraordinaire et on fait
les mêmes choses pour les yeux les
aveugles qu'on peut faire voir et le
choc
de psychothérapie qui peut durer des
semaines des semaines et des mois parce
que apprendre tout d'un coup avoir des
bruits qu'on a jamais entendu d'abord
c'est un bruit et ce bruit veut dire
quelque chose c'est ça il faut la
prendre il faut le réapprendre et c'est
très difficile la même chose pour les
les aveugles qui n'ont jamais vu et la
première fois qu'on a fait ça on avait
implanté des des
électrodes sur le cerveau pour que les
gens voient et ils voyaient à l'envers
alors nous on ne peut pas le savoir
donc ce sont les images et les dessins
qu'il faisait qui nous ont fait
comprendre qu'il voyait à l'envers quel
courage un professeur ensuite tu te fais
extraordinaire et puis surtout cette
joie de vivre
parce que moi la première fois que qu'on
m'a parlé de Brenda
j'étais même moi j'étais un peu nerveuse
la première fois on m'a envoyé à New
York alors pour rencontrer Brenda Brenda
pour me rencontrer on nous a mis dans
une pièce on était les deux on se
regardait un peu comme ça et en fait
c'est quelqu'un de c'est vraiment
incroyable parce que elle est tellement
sensible et avant que je dise des choses
elle sait très bien ce que je veux dire
et ça et il y a plein de choses elle est
très moi j'adore me promener avec elle
parce que si je veux comprendre quelque
chose elle lit les lèvres à son maître
c'est génial parce que vraiment c'est
génial sortira mais non mais c'est vrai
même dans les shootings parce que les
gens pensent à elle écoute pas alors
Brenda c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
intelligente
elle comprend tout alors elle voit tout
alors c'est plein de fois dans les
shooting il y a eu des gens qui ont dit
oui mais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là ou
pourquoi on nous avons elle est belle
mais elle va rien comprendre et ça c'est
terrible c'est c'est triste de voir ça
parce qu'elle comprend très bien
elle aime bien lutter il y a aucun
problème
que je voudrais savoir le problème là si
je veux draguer Brenda je suis obligé
vous êtes obligé d'être là quoi
d'ailleurs je l'ai jamais vu embrasser
d'ailleurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu